all right let's play favorites alright
your favorite drag look from your first
time on the show my favorite look that I
did on the show was the big blue gown
what's the crazy blonde hair with that
we did for the ballet it was like you
could only see it for like 15 seconds
Rio so what was your least favorite look
great I knew you were gonna say your
favorite challenge my favorite challenge
was the roast eating everybody to Phil
you are younger than the fire island
production of rent your least favorite
challenge my least favorite
mini-challenge was The Crying Game
because I opened up a lot of weird
emotional things event it like
completely set par for the rest of the
season I lost my boyfriend two years ago
things that I do and do not want to
share and obviously that was something
that came up unexpectedly but you'll
find out you got during all-stars
favorite co-star or queen I don't want
to pick favorites well who's your
favorite Queen to watch perform or
lip-sync my favorite Queen to watch
perform out of the series sure yeah yeah
favorite song to lip-synch what's your
go-to my signature number is uh
nothing's gonna stop us now from the
movie we had a can I do this one
mannequin thing but my favorite song to
ever lip-sync is how can I ease the pain
by Lisa for sure because I love doing
crazy ballets no one ever knows but like
no one really expects detox to come out
and like power ballad your lips she
technique is very interesting let me see
it oh so your jaw is so enhance I guess
I'm like a snake hey guys thanks for
watching ET on YouTube for more great
videos be sure to click to subscribe